what I want to do in this video is think
about the two different ways of
interpreting lowercase G which as we've
talked about before many textbooks will
give you as either 9.81 m/s^2 downward
or towards the center Earth's center or
sometimes it's given with a negative
quantity that signifies the direction it
was essentially downwards negative 9.81
m/s^2
and probably the most typical way to
interpret this value as the acceleration
so let me write acceleration due to
gravity due to gravity near near Earth's
surface near Earth's surface for an
object in freefall and this is what
we're going to focus on in this video
for an object object in freefall and the
reason why I'm stressing this last part
is because imagine or we know of many
objects that are near the surface of the
earth that are not in freefall for
example I am near the surface of the
earth right now and I am NOT in freefall
what's happening to me right now is I'm
sitting in a chair and so this is my
chair draw a little stick drawing of my
chair and this is me this is me and
let's just say that chair supporting all
my weight so my legs are flying in the
air so this is me and so what's
happening right now if I were in
freefall I would be accelerating towards
the center of the earth at 9.81 m/s^2
but what's happening is is all of the
force due to gravity so all of the force
due to gravity is being completely
offset by the normal force from the
surface of the chair onto my onto my
pants and so so this is normal force and
all right make them both as vectors I'll
make them both as vectors so the net
force so the net force in my situation
the net force is equal to zero
especially in this vertical direction
and because the net force is equal
zero I am not accelerating towards the
center of the earth I am not in freefall
and because this nine point eight one
eight one meters per second squared
still seems relevant to my situation and
I'll talk about that a second but I'm
not an object in freefall another way to
interpret this is not as the
acceleration due to gravity near Earth's
surface for an object in freefall
although it is that may be a more
general way to interpret this as the
gravitational or Earth's gravitational
field or it's really the average
acceleration or the average because it
actually changes slightly throughout the
surface of the earth but another way to
view this as the average gravitational
field at Earth's surface let me write
that way in pink so the average
gravitational field and we'll talk about
what a field means in the physics
context in a second field
the average gravitational field at at
Earth's surface and this is a little bit
more of an abstract thing we'll talk
about that in a second but it does help
us think about how G is related to this
scenario where I am NOT an object in
freefall a field when you think of it in
the physics context slightly more
abstract notion when you start think
about in the mathematics context but in
the physics context a field is just
something that Associates a quantity
with every point in space so this is
just a quantity quantity with every
point point in space and it can actually
be a scalar quantity in which case we
would call it a scalar field in which
case would just be a value or it could
be a vector quantity which would be a
magnitude and a direction associated
with every point in space in which case
you are dealing with a vector field and
the reason why this is called a field is
because at near Earth's surface
near Earth's surface if you give me a
mass so for example I don't actually I
don't know what my mass is in kilograms
but if you're a near Earth surface and
you give me a mass so let's say that
mass right over there is 10 kilograms
you can use G to figure out the actual
force on that
of gravity on that object at that point
in at that point in space so for example
if this has a mass I mean this has a
mass of 10 kilograms then we know in
this right over here is the surface of
the earth so that's the center of the
earth so it actually Associates a vector
quantity whose magnitude so it's
Direction is towards the center of the
earth and the magnitude of this vector
quantity is going to be the mass times
times G times and you could take since
we're already specifying the direction
we could say 9.81 m/s^2
towards the center of the earth and so
in this situation it would be 10
kilograms 10 kilograms times 9.81 9.81
m/s^2 which is 98 98.1 and even this
i've rounded a little bit so it's it's
actually approximate number 98.1
kilogram meters per second squared or
which is also a unit which is the unit
of force or 98.1 newtons and this thing
might not be in freefall and so this is
this is why it becomes why G is relevant
even in a situation where the object
isn't in freefall G has given us the
force per unit mass the force per mass
of of groove of gravity on an object
near the surface of the earth so this
let me another way to think about it so
this is the average gravitational field
and what it's giving is what it's giving
is force force per mass so you give me a
mass near Earth's surface whether it's
an object in freefall or not you
multiply that mass times G because it's
giving you force per mass and it will
give you Earth's gravity it'll give you
the force of gravity acting on that
object near the surface of the earth
whether or not it's in freefall so I
just want to make this little
distinction because although G tends to
be referred to this way right over here
sometimes you might encounter a stickler
who says oh no no no no but G is
relevant even when an object is not in
freefall you obviously can't say that my
acceleration when I'm sitting in my
chair is 9.81 m/s^2 towards the center
of the earth I am NOT accelerating
towards the center of the earth and so
they'll say oh no no no it's you you
can't just call this you can't just call
this acceleration it is true
- it is the acceleration when an object
is in free fall when near the surface of
the earth if you don't have really air
resistance if gret if the net force
really is the force of gravity then this
really would be the object's
acceleration but it becomes relevant and
we know most objects that we know if
aren't in freefall obviously an object
in freefall doesn't stay in freefall for
long it eventually hits something but we
know that now G is actually relevant to
all objects it tells us the force per
mass as tempting to call it always
acceleration because the units are
acceleration but even when you talk
about it in terms of the gravitational
field is still the same quantity it
still has it still has the exact same
units the same magnitude and the same
direction it's just a different way of
viewing it here acceleration for an
object in freefall here something to
multiply by mass to figure out the force
due to gravity